brandon so good to see you back here uh
there's been such an outpouring of love
your old co-star dwayne robert johnson
even tweeted out his love and admiration
for you with this what does that feel
like
a real shot in the arm although he has a
pretty big shot so i should say really
good really good dwayne
when you got that massive standing
ovation in venice what did you and
darren talk about immediately after well
first he told me don't get out of your
chair until i tell you to
i did
we said thank you
we thought it was time to go get
something cold to drink and then he said
come back take a bow
he's the boss so he did
and um
i guess i smiled really really hard am i
just sprained my cheek muscle or
something because my face started
leaking
not sure why maybe it was being in italy
oh what an ovation that that was a first
for me really exciting these people are
out here chanting your name and calling
you over to come and see them tell me
about the emotion involved in going out
there right to that crowd
well i hope they don't push into each
other too much um
i'm i'm happy to meet all the fans it's
it's nice to see each other up close and
personal again that we can do this um
so it's we're celebrating
more things than just the opening of a
film we're celebrating
the opening of cinema again it's
exciting that's wonderful thank you sir
you're welcome